what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here and it's John over here so we're
going to talk about some movie news of
the week or howdy all right here we go
so for a full extended movie news
segment you can go over to our patreon
but we'll cover the top two biggest ones
over here
today starting off with then a movie the
vented movie it's announced that the
villain in it is going to be the popular
spider-man villain carnage carnage is
going to be in here and a little will
break down a note that we took here is
it in the comics its cleanest Cassidy
and Cassidy he had he was a prison
cellmate with Brock yeah
hey penny Brock yeah is a prison
cellmate with Brock Brock escaped with
the symbiote and then to send me I left
some behind like who gets a abarenov it
out of there will be seven of these
mothers and people so who sells
basically okay I I think I just kind of
seemed like a repetitive thing to have
like Oh too bad
auntie spider-man venom versus worse
than yeah but that's really the only
thing I guess they can do to make venom
stand out a little bit more is give you
two villains we've been really wanting
to see you a spider-man movie yeah yeah
and I you know I guess it makes sense
that venom should be the protagonist
that's a little I guess it's a little
kooky to me I know he's got his own
comics I mean I'm kind of not that weird
I'm kind of worried that I might be
watching this movie with venom and
carnage in it going ah two people or
like spider-man with spider-man's on it
and I don't know this could go like I
can see a version of this where I get
really invested because I do just like
venom I thought venom was really cool I
have been a memorabilia and I even back
when I was like trying to get more into
comics I bought some venom solo books
yeah um but it's gonna have to be like
really well-done for me to not be
thinking about what Iron Man the one
good thing about it though is that at
least venom
the movie because as much as we wanted
to see venom rebooted and put in as
spider-man the villain in a solo
spider-man film at least we're going to
get carnage being introduced as a
villain in on some antihero like how
Venom's being introduced here because so
yeah so so like venom is the antihero
and then carnage is worse urban crazier
vendor ID or lots of power some well
similar to venom in spider-man but I
don't know I feel like that could be a
good idea actually because I feel like
it's a good way to kind of give us the
whole idea of you know it was like
spider-man versing venom with spider-man
versing bad version of spider-man now
it's like okay well venom and now we'll
get that worse version of venom versing
each other and this could be like an
ultimate Daddy fest I feel of the anti
spider-man 10 have you down one yeah I
mean this is you know a decent way to
open up to including the seven symbiotes
and all that so yeah and if this is
connecting we haven't gotten any
clarification yet from Kevin Feige since
that hilarious means we're going around
to sense ie
whatever they did with Ben Affleck but
if it is connected in any way to the MCU
if they are if that is true Amy Pascal
you know saying that it's connected to
the MCU world if that is that remains
true um it would be cool if you have
like these people who were you know
bursting each other in one movie and
then maybe in down the runner in a
spider-man movie they're now teaming up
to like take down spider-man at the same
time I would have just preferred if
spider-man vs. venom in a solo movie
it's very less garbage in a solo movie
but at the same time people might find
that in terms of movie world a little
repetitive if you're just getting to
evil spider-man for two separate
spider-man Hans you you bring carnage in
an act 3 yeah love that thing you get
carnage and venom all in this one movie
and so so I think this could be a really
cool thing actually yeah I mean this
definitely brings me back over to the Oh
talk about them checkout minute side of
the FX
so yeah I know people been looking
forward to carnage and I have been too
and some people prefer carnage over them
yes
so either way you could get exactly yeah
that's why I think it would be cool
because you're getting two of the anti
Spider Men reversing each other in this
one movie which i think is one way to
make it a cool standalone venom set to
shove the Lord and Chris Miller they
have left the Han Solo project with only
three and a half weeks left the film
supposedly oh boy that's not much time
to creative differences and from
everything I've read which is a lot
lately sounds like there was a pretty
pretty big creative differences yeah I
think a lot of it comes down to the fact
that Phil Lord and Chris Miller they
like to infuse a lot of humor and then
you get rather meta whether human to and
I'd imagine they're doing a han Solo
origin story or I don't know if talking
about his birthday you know I mean like
a lot of the Lumia Belkin the cub at
mon-sol yeah yeah so if you're having
all that in there I'd imagine they would
infuse a lot of comedy and maybe even
make some meta references in their film
which I'm sure would not go well with
you know the with Disney over with their
Star Wars songs wasn't my not suspect
only at all with the rest of their
movies yeah so I could kind of
understand the creative differences
however I wanted the Lord and Chris
Miller to do that I was I thought like
that I feel like you know force awakens
especially with Row one being a prequel
movie then a different kind of star well
yeah maybe a little bit it would I feel
like I would have made it different it
could have been a really fun I feel like
a little bit cool to get a really funny
han solo move because Han Solo he is the
funniest one out of the original crew
you know yeah he has a sense of humor
and I would have I would have been okay
with that and now they've got Ron Howard
step in here take over the director's
seat for the remainder of filming and
reshoots post which I guess is fine and
I think it's honestly think it's cause
it's not it's not the hiring of Ron
Howard that has caused me to doubt the
quality of this film it's it's the fact
a director has left a few weeks left in
the filming and now that it's like it
doesn't matter who they would get in to
take up the mantle here yeah I feel I
can regardless I'd be concerned I know
and I am concerned for the film because
you know like this is very much a studio
executive movie at this point it's not I
felt like what was cool about road one
was Gareth Evans Edwards Edwards yeah I
care there yeah boy Godzilla monster yes
yes Gareth Edwards
I thought his version of it was like
yeah this seems like what Garrett there
were set out to do and he and he was
able to do it I know they had some
reshoots and some conflicts over with
Disney but seems like overall he got to
make a pretty unique standalone Star
Wars film and here it just seems like
they're really trying to mold it into
what the studio execs want it to be and
Ron Howard just seems like a filling
directory just seems like someone who's
going to do what the studio's ex wanted
to do because Ron Howard a hasn't had a
hit or a good movie in a very long time
I feel like the last one he did that was
well received was rushed no one really
turned out for that then he got films
like the third DaVinci burner or no in
the heart of the C dilemma
he got these yeah it's a pretty awful
Ron Howard films and I'm just thinking
he's gonna just show up and he's if he's
just gonna do what these studio execs
want him to do he's not gonna bring
anything really unique to it oh I feel
like that would be anybody coming into
this position now cuz they said I heard
the other rumor was Joe Johnston no like
I feel like that would have been a
better choice it's the thing about Ron
Howard too is like even though his
filmography has gotten shaky lately if
he's going to step into Star Wars I
would want that to be for his own Star
Wars yeah and not for the last three
weeks of this story yeah yeah you know
and those are a shorthand like good you
get a good at least a proven film matter
sure is like a good example of this was
Superman 2 with ruff
damn oh it's a key Robert Downey jr.
Burton and juniors who is the director
of it again oh no there's you know like
their daughter Richard Donner yeah
Richard dawn with Richard Donner
Superman - how like 70 to 80% of that
film shot and then they had another
director come in to finish up the rest
of the movie and Superman - wasn't a bad
film it's definitely better than
Superman three and four and better than
Superman Returns and but people really
loved the Richard Donner or Superman -
cut that he put together yeah that was
really cool Anna and I know they didn't
finish filming on this but I feel like
it might be kind of cool to get a cut of
Phil Lord and Chris Miller I I don't
know if they have enough footage to
actually put one together but it would
be cool to get that I just think that
you when you do this you're probably and
with everything that Phil Lord and Chris
Miller shot I'm sure the mid
disagreements all along the way of
filming this movie
I can't imagine just oh it's over the
last few weeks when we start having
disagreements then we left I'd imagine
there's disagreements all around so
you're probably going I feel like we'll
get some tonal inconsistency some weird
structure I just that's what I worry
about when you replace a director this
late into the game of filming oh yeah I
mean I this story - I don't know at this
point what to feel about this movie
anymore because the more stories I've
read about it the more just shaky the
whole enterprise becomes because you
think about how big and how many moving
parts these movies have like they've got
to be approved before you go in and I
heard you know the whoever the lead
actor is said like he was the first one
to bring up concerns about like know
their own set demeanor is a little laid
back and they're changing stuff around
and now it feels like a Jim Carrey
comedy yeah and so like I'm hearing that
I'm like well this does sound strange
you know and and yeah like there seems
to be such a dissonance with this
project and I don't know you know who is
sniping at who and why so yeah this is
sound this is coming across to me like a
big old mess and and if you're bringing
somebody in to fix it by the end I what
it sounds like it sounds like they're
gonna have to reshoot Oh a lot out of it
yeah we should cuz we wanted Chris
Miller shot most of the movie already
didn't eat like and yeah it's like Ron
Howard style was totally different if
the Lord Ingram's Miller's time yeah and
and like I get why it's distressing
you're like oh like really broad comedy
and I know Disney said like you know
where they're going for more the comedic
angle on Han Solo instead of the you
know scoundrel angle and I'm like he's a
scoundrel but he's a piece - laughing no
he's not that man yeah yeah he's a fine
guy enough so uh yeah I have very kind
of low expectations for how this is
gonna turn out right now ma'am has
alright guys well like we said earlier
you can catch our full segment over at
patreon cover cough you more stories so
I do on youtubes we get the biggest one
but and then patreon we discover like
the ones we throughout the week that we
thought were 60% more you you really
like knocking it up so you really like
it it took the dumb you know like hear
us talk about the news of the week or
tried notification bowels John Humphrey
- on Humphrey links and social media all
in the description box go check it out
good bye